the realm
do you know what the realm is
it's the Thousand Blades of aegon's
enemies
a story we agreed to tell each other
over and
we forget that it's a lie
what's up ladies and gentlemen welcome
back for another Game of Thrones in
House of the Dragon update video in this
video I will be revealing some new
information about House of the dragon's
most divisive scenes as you all know
near the end of House of the dragon's
first season aegon's coronation was held
in King's Landing almost immediately
after the death of his father King
viserys Targaryen as rhaenyra was on
Dragonstone unaware of her father's
death aegon was crowned as the new king
of Westeros and the dragon pit of King's
Landing as thousands of onlookers were
witnessing this historic event and right
as aegon started to fully Embrace this
moment rhaenys Targaryen in her Dragon
melees came smashing through the floor
of the venue leading to the sudden death
of hundreds or even thousands of the
city's residents not only did this shock
everyone who is there at aegon's
coronation but it shocked millions of
House of the Dragons fans as well now
before I go any further I have to let
all of you know about this amazing new
offer I'd like to thank the sponsor of
today's video Ridge wallet say goodbye
to your bulky old wallet and jump into
the 21st century with the ridge wallet
and key case this Sleek wallet holds up
to 12 cards plus there's still room for
cash there are over 30 colors and styles
to choose from including carbon fiber
and my favorite the barn titanium the
wallets are made with RFID blocking
technology that protects you from
digital pickpocketers and the durable
material means that each wallet comes
with a lifetime warranty plus the ridge
team is so confident that you'll like it
they'll let you test drive it for 45
days you can send it back for a full
refund if you don't love it but I know
you will the wallets have over 50 000
five-star reviews I love the way this
wallet fits in my pocket and I know you
will too the key case is a simple and
convenient fix to Bulky keychains it
holds all of your keys in place quietly
this key case has really been a game
changer for me I no longer have to carry
two sets of keys and the best part about
it for me is that it hooks right onto
your belt loop or your lanyard get the
best offer on your wallet and key case
with my link reged com slash talking
Thrones and right now you can save forty
percent through December 22nd thanks
again to Ridge wallet for partnering
with me on today's video now as you all
know after the episode ended there was
an endless amount of fans on social
media saying rhaenys was now a murderer
what made this even worse for a lot of
fans was how rainey's allowed aegon
Allison and Serato to live another day I
think a lot of the fans felt that if
rainey's was gonna murder anyone then it
should have been the hightowers instead
of hundreds or thousands of innocent
citizens of King's Landing well
according to this new information the
original scene was actually much worse
than what we saw in the episode we only
saw a fraction of what rhaenys and her
Dragon melees done before they left the
scene I want to have a look at the new
article so you can see exactly what
happened it says House of the dragon's
coronation nearly involved much more
death The House of the Dragon coronation
in episode 9 almost involved a lot more
Blood and Guts and rhaenys was involved
here's why it didn't happen whenever
there's some big event like a wedding or
a coronation fans of the fantasy series
Game of Thrones and its new successor
show how so the dragon are ready for the
worst as we all know these sort of
celebrations do not usually end well for
those who live in Westeros so no one
should really be that shocked to learn
that the coronation and House of the
Dragon episode 9 was nearly much much
more bloody now during an interview at
Screen Rant VFX supervisor Mike Bell
revealed new information about that
coronation scene and how rainey's exit
on our Dragon almost resulted in a hell
of a lot more death he said initially
rainy smashes into and runs over crowds
of people on top of her Dragon resulting
in the death of thousands VFX supervisor
Mike Bell also said the coronation in
episode 9 ended up being done a little
bit differently in the episode we aired
on HBO especially when rainy's exits
because we initially had shots where she
exits in smashes right through thousands
of residents and it was just like well
that's not really into the feeling of
the character there's definitely a
feeling like is it okay that she's just
going through all this crowd we
initially started out with a higher
number where there was a lot more death
but then we reduced it down but in all
that dust there's also people flying in
somersaulting I think if you froze it
you might be able to count them it's
hundreds or maybe even thousands and
that's easy to believe and fans are more
than used to the death of Innocence
especially in King's Landing however
Mike Bell's reason for the switch also
makes a lot of sense and it may have
stuck out as something that wasn't
necessarily in line without rhaenys had
acted for the rest of the season so if
you actually watch that scene you really
only see them die as her and her Dragon
smash through the floor when rainy's
inner dragon fly away from the scene you
don't see them run over anyone at least
not very many however as you can see
here in the new article they initially
had her and melee's murdering even more
residents as she was fleeing from the
scene I'm sure you can certainly
understand stand why they did this a
little differently in the final version
of that episode there were already
enough fans angry with what rhaenys did
now you might be able to argue that she
had no other way of getting her dragon
out of there without smashing through
the ground like that but it would also
be a lot harder to defend her if she
just went running over thousands of more
innocent lives as she was leaving that
does sound a lot more malicious what's
interesting is it does sound like they
did shoot these scenes with the added
VFX during the interview he said they
had shots of the original scene where
she runs over thousands more as she was
exiting the dragon pit I do wonder if we
will ever get to see those somewhere
maybe they will add it to the deleted
scenes when they release the DVD extras
so what do all of you think about this
new information in regards to that
already very divisive scene would this
have actually made any difference at all
since so many already died before
rhaenys and melees left the coronation
do any of you think this would have made
the scene better or worse as always I
want to thank all of you for stopping by
and watching another one of my videos
those I hope everyone has a great day
and I also hope everyone enjoys the
holidays I will see you back here again
very soon bye
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]